hey everybody I have a lauren zima here
to talk about episode number two of The
Bachelorette
also known as the night we met Chad
that's Chad now I gotta give Chad credit
he came out strong as a villain in
Episode two we learned a lot about him
like he hates sensitivity he just being
super sensitive
Chad hates effort Nik is trying so hard
it's just coming off super weird
Chad hates being nice I always warn
girls I always say I stay away from the
nice guy so the whole episode Chad said
that he was being honest and acted like
that justified his behavior all I'm
doing is calling things like they are
and then get distracting us by eating
everything in sight you don't want the
meat on a stick it's delicious now I
don't know if he's here for the free
food or if he's here to find love but we
were not distracted Chad we know that
you are officially this season's villain
and you know what I embrace it I was
entertained y'all don't know her yet you
can't be in love with her like if you
are that's weird things ended in an even
more unexpected way than they began with
Chad insulting the Care Bears and
showing us that he has a fairly
impressive knowledge of musical you are
the most disrespectful dude in this
entire house it was like if the Care
Bears like surrounded you and told you
they're gonna kick your ass it was like
watching West Side Story what you do is
just like okay surrounding me then Chad
you might hate being sensitive you might
hate being nice but you sure don't hate
a dance number just coming in a circle
all right let's get Chad guys I can't
thank all this coming from Chad is him
having some issues with himself what do
you think either way I love to watch it
and I want to know your thoughts I am on
twitter at lauren zima and I found
Chad's Twitter name so just get us all
involved